they had sexual allegations against
marilyn manson
you know and i don't know what the guy
did i don't know
but i would you know i don't know if he
i i and i don't think he was messing
with underage women
i think he was dating of age women
but i'll say this some lady they said
she said they found out she had a sex
dungeon
and he was trying to hit her with a
wigwams or something dildos sorry
um
by looking at marilyn manson
that should give you a 99 idea
that this dude don't be
[ __ ] regular you know what i'm saying
he ain't [ __ ] regular
he'll put on a condom that has edgar
allen poe's autograph on the side of it
you know
you have to like
if you if you go to dinner with them and
they serve in vulture
you gotta think oh he probably going to
have an extra dick or two on him you
know what i'm saying like
you can't look at that guy
and think that things are going to be
regular i don't think
i'm not blaming anybody i'm just saying
you have to have like because the lady
said oh he was scary or something
but i'm just saying look
the dude is doing 365
days of halloween okay
this dude does halloween like a
instagram
thought does her birthday all right it's
a two-month deal i bet
this dude probably [ __ ] you know
he'll probably
you know this dude got licorice under
his armpits for good luck i'm just
saying
you can't look at marilyn manson's
and expect that he ain't gonna be
skeeting asphalt or something you know
what you just you can't look at him
the dude looks like the saw movies
i remember i'll tell you this you know
and i and i've had
i've had a i was almost molested
you know or semi-molested or whatever at
a marilyn manson
show they had a man this man
uh richard langenstein they called him
dickie
and he was a senior citizen and he was
he had um what's it called when it looks
like you have snow on your arm but
uh it's like a
i think um scabies or something i don't
know what it is
hold on let me look it up
he had um
seven causes of white spots on your skin
mycosis bro i don't know if he had that
[ __ ] he didn't have that
man dermatite dermatitis
eczema brought uh maybe yeah i think he
had eggs in my bro
i think he had that hypodemonicism
scholar sclerosis
i don't know bro he was [ __ ] spotted
up you know what i'm saying he was that
speckled molester
you know he was that um he was that uh
you know he was that you know he was
that dicky dalmatian kind of guy
well he took me and my best friend at
the time
patrick he we were 14.
we was 14 we met him through church and
he took us to the
marilyn manson show and dropped us off
in there
and dude it was 18 and over
and he took one of my friends to las
vegas i think it might have pedophiled
him i don't know
but but i do know and i think that's
what happened but um
but anyway what happened was hold on
so richard langenstein and he deceased
now humans to jail for pedophilin bro
for peaf island but
um was i telling you oh we went to
marilyn manson's
on stage he cut his friend open with a
beer bottle and the ambulance came
i remember being in the bathroom
my friend and i are peeing and it's
taking a long time
because everyone around us
smells like voldemort
and we're peeing as a guy behind me
eating [ __ ] charcoal briquettes bro
it's
the dark arts
and somebody said to someone else they
said man
these kids are pretty young to be in
here
and somebody else goes yeah somebody's
gonna
them tonight and they said f word [ __ ]
so anyway bruh uh
you know what was i talking about dude
this is for better help what is this um
i don't even know
it's just like but i know that when i'm
going to maryland
i know i'm going to i know
that i'm entering you know be
al's a bubbs [ __ ] i know
that they gonna have crows in the
corners of the room
you know i know that if marilyn manson
spits on my back
that the that the saliva is gonna
slither off down my
arm into a drain and procreate a demon
i know
now i don't know everything
but i have some responsibility as a
human to
lightly assume that things are going to
be risque
and i knew that at 14.
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one